bonjour à tous avant de commencer cette
vidéo aliénor a une annonce à vous faire
oui je vais dire qu'une annonce
importante si tu me laisses parler je
dois juste une annonce qui va changer
votre vie n'exagérons pas mais cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par mehdi - car
d'entreprise de gastronomie médiévale
dont nous vous reparlerons en fin de
vidéo mais dis moi car mehdi c'est ma
période
[Musique]
bref avant tout aujourd'hui on va parler
de superstition de croyance
d'aiguillettes nous et d'hommes se
change en commande d'un culte vraiment
tu veux dire que la plupart de ses
croyances ne proviennent pas de ton
époque un boom and tube she don't you ou
pour commencer donc d'où viennent les
croyances du moyen âge j'aime le dire d
autre part à la géode fire aujourd'hui
comme jeanne d'arc
ok on reprend au au moyen-âge bien que
le christianisme se développent les
cultes païens persiste longtemps on
trouve encore un culte des sources et
des fontaines au 6e siècle des
sacrifices d'enfants en neuvième siècle
chez les frisons certaines de ces
croyances sont transmises via les textes
où les pratiques religieuses romaine
c'est le cas de beaucoup de fêtes
religieuses comme celle des calendes ou
de vulcain qui sont encore pratiquées au
6e siècle l'église réagi en interdisant
de porter un masque de serre ou des
peaux de bête puis en interdisant
totalement les fêtes des calendes au
viiie siècle
aucun sens de la fête mais parce que
tout le haut moyen-âge et marquée par un
conflit entre le paganisme et l'église
les gens continuent de porter les
amulettes l'église interdit le port dos
d'animaux en 1813 les gens interprètent
les rêves l'église interdit la
divination par le rêve en 789 les gens
au fond de la sorcellerie on interdit la
sorcellerie dans à peu près toutes les
lois de l'époque avoue que ce n'est pas
une réussite
la raison principale c'est qu'on cherche
à étendre le christianisme bien sûr la
raison évoquée est étudié par les clercs
c'est le début le démon le léman bleu
dément les potions celle des monts
prémonition celle des monts l'adoration
les arbres et des sources et les mots
lire l'avenir dans les fientes c'est le
bon à quel champion ce démon qu'il
s'agisse de survivance de culte antique
romain scène scandinave l'église
considère tout ce qui ne correspond pas
à ce qu'elle enseigne comme de la
superstition
inspiré par le démon pour saint-augustin
la superstition c'est tout ce qui a été
instituée par les hommes en vue de la
fabrication et du culte des idoles tout
ce qui tend soit adoré comme dieu la
création ou une de ces parties mais
aussi ceux qui consiste soit à consulter
les démons soit à conclure avec eux par
des signes convenu d pacte d'alliance
pour martin de braga évêques au 6e
siècle
mais dieu païen tels que neptune dans la
mer les lamy dans lé fleuve aude yade
dans les forêts sont en fait des démons
on a compris à du franc tellement cher
dans cet épisode
ap j'adore pour remplacer ces cultes en
douceur grégoire le grand ordonne de
réutiliser les édifices religieux payen
pour les transformer en bonne église
mais le synode de nantes 2 658 décide
finalement de détruire tous les lieux de
culte païen
même les arbres sa vénérée cet arbre
tapez neyret septembre ben tu vas voir
et pourtant certains trucs reste tolérée
l'église interdit les divinations par le
rêve mais les visions ce dans la bible
donc ça passe les européens se
convertissent progressivement
d'angleterre au viiie siècle de suède au
xième siècle mais pas mal de croyances
païennes demeure certains font leur
petit mélange n'hésitant pas à consulter
à la fois le prêtre et le devin certains
peuples germains récemment convertis
sont par exemple pas très partants pour
abandonner les sacrifices parce que
c'était vachement festif
du coup au lieu de faire des sacrifices
à leurs anciens dieux ils en font au
sein pas sûr que l'église apprécié le
culte des saints et des martyrs se
développe d'ailleurs d'après certains
historiens pour combler le vide laissé
par les anciens dieux
les gens n'avaient pas l'habitude de
consulter les dieux majeur dans leurs
anciennes religions une préféré
s'adresser à des dieux du quotidien
proche de l écoute de leurs problèmes et
c'est cet office que remplissent
désormais les seins et l'église a du mal
à faire comprendre aux gens que même si
on peut prier les seins c'est dieu qui
est à l'origine de leur pouvoir
on retrouve aussi du paganisme dans les
jours de la semaine que césaire d'arles
essai de christianiser au 6e siècle sans
succès
cette survivance de pratiques païennes
est loin de concerner le petit peuple
qui mangent pas du homard tous les jours
brett valdes un roi des angles du 6e
siècle revient à ses croyances païennes
bien qu'ils étaient converties chez nous
la reine frédégonde engagement
chasse aux sorcières païenne soi disant
responsables de la mort de son fils en
584 et la chasse aux sorcières on prend
bien fort à mon époque et ça on en a
déjà parlé dans une autre vidéo
et puis certaines croyances antique qui
relève du merveilleux reste plutôt bien
accepté elles sont transmises par des
textes tels que l'histoire naturelle de
pline l'ancien les métamorphoses d ovide
on y trouve des descriptions de pays où
coulent des fleuves de pierres
précieuses des ânes marins et des hommes
à tête de chien mais ça c'est tranquille
pourquoi pas faut être tolérant
on reparlera un peu de ce merveilleux en
fin d'épisode parce qu'il connaît un
grand regain d'intérêt au 3e siècle
avant ça on en arrive aux carreaux
d'agen qui continue de supporter ces
superstitions païenne qui voudraient pas
vous coller mais ça va être le même
refrain sur toute la période mais se
répéter tient place nd du bas non parce
que de nouveautés
sinon la vie des autres et finit à
l'époque carolingienne l'église devient
maître de la culture savante
c'est elle qui recopient les textes
antiques donc c'est elle qui censurent
thomas d'aquin s'intéresse à la nature
de la superstition et décrivant comme un
péché par excès car elle rend un culte à
qui elle ne le devraient pas ou l heure
en mal
c'est une des mesures du culte divin un
ajout superflu ou néfaste inspiré par le
diable tout ça n'empêche pas les gens de
créer de nouvelles superstition à partir
du christianisme par exemple avec le
culte des saints les gens amènent des
enfants malades sur des tombeaux ou font
des offrandes qui n'aurait rien à envier
aux cultes païens comme par exemple en
plantant des clous dans les arbres
associé au sein du rugby de culte des
saints passe par leurs reliques puisque
l'église admis qu'ils peuvent agir à
travers elle
du coup les gens plongent leur tête dans
les tombeaux des saints ou mélange de la
poussière des tombeaux à du vin ou de
l'eau en guise de médicaments
on appelle ça le village mais l'église
craint que ce mélange soit vendu ou
utilisés à des fins magique et non
thérapeutique
elle reproche aussi aux gens de vouer un
culte trop forts à l'image des saints et
de se détourner un peu trop vite de si
leurs voeux ne sont pas exaucé à partir
du neuvième siècle les textes parlent de
plus en plus de pratiques magiques et
recommande aux prêtres de mettre en
garde leurs fidèles face au sortilège
qui sont rappelons le
l'oeuvre du démon il vise les
incantations médical transmises par des
manuscrits antiques des maléfices visant
à rendre les hommes impuissants ou au
contraire a provoqué l'amour sincères et
un poisson dans le
dans le cas par exemple
et puis le faire manger à son mari les
maléfices visant à s'approprier des
biens en demandant les services des
faux-nez nam qui vivent dans les
environs les maléfices visant à
contrôler la météo en aspergeant une
jeune fille vierge l'eau de pluie à
travers ces pratiques de magie blanche
on peut observer les principales
préoccupations des habitants du
moyen-âge rural b récolte et la
possession de biens assez peu de
maléfices vise à acquérir de l'argent
parce qu'il a peu court dans ces
sociétés rurales il qu'on préfère
demander au phone de voler les biens du
voisin toutes ces croyances nous sont
connus grâce à des pénitents ciel comme
celui de ben hur cher de vorms rédigé au
xième siècle
ils font la liste des pratiques
interdites par l'église de manière très
détaillée et impose une peine plus ou
moins lourdes en fonction de ces
pratiques
bouchard devant nous est assez peu
sévère à l'encontre des fidèles qui se
livrent à ce genre de superstition parce
qu'il considère qu'il s'agit de croyance
saute ou inspirées par le démon on
trouve aussi dans ce pénitentielle des
passages repris quelques siècles plus
tard lors de la chasse aux sorcières as
tu partages et la croyance de certaines
femmes que dans le silence de la nuit
porte fermée avec d'autres disciples du
diable tu es capable de monter en l'air
jusqu'aux nuages et sorcières ne sont
d'ailleurs pas une invention médiévale
les romains croyait déjà en des
créatures semblables appelé astier rejet
durant l'époque carolingienne l'hélice
continue aussi son travail de
remplacement des fêtes païennes par des
fêtes chrétiennes
un travail de longue haleine puisqu'il
s'impose dans les villes dès le 5ème
siècle mais dans les campagnes c'est pas
encore ça
on continue de fêter les lupercales même
si les gens y voient plus du folklore
qu'une vraie croyance en fait le
solstice d'été à la place de la
saint-jean le culte de l'ours très
important chez beaucoup de païens
demeure durant tout le moyen âge et bien
que l'église place l'esa important sur
chaque jour où c'était la fête de l'ours
auparavant la fête de l'ours qui
hibernent a fait 2 lorsqu'il sort de sa
tanière au 10ème siècle une distinction
entre le monde urbain et le monde rural
s'opère on passe d'un monde clérical is
aimé ou des superstitions païenne
demeure à un monde urbain instruit d'un
côté et un monde rural un peu con de
l'autre ça c'est le point de vue des
urbains les paysans possède désormais
une culture plutôt folkloriques dont il
aime bien se moquer c'est surtout que
les gens des villes ne comprennent plus
rien ou très nombreuses croyances des
paysans beaucoup d'entre elles sont
compilés par gervais de tilbury un clair
du deuxième siècle
parmi elles on trouve beaucoup de
croyances liées aux animaux les cordages
sont de bons conseils les signes
porte-bonheur romarin et lièvres ou les
chèvres porte malheur les cigales
favorise les voyages et puis il ya les
croyances en des créatures étranges
gervais de tilbury mentionne les hommes
qui se change en août selon le cycle de
la lune et dont il faut couper un
membres pour qu'ils retrouvent leur
apparence il ya aussi plein d'histoires
de fait qu'on retrouve aussi bien dans
la culture populaire que dans la
littérature savante elles sont nommées
par que dans l'antiquité
s'il faut la mia dans le haut moyen-âge
gamme abondent à mon époque
bref les faits ont pas mal de noms
souvent leye à l'illusion la nature la
mort la noblesse et la beauté elle
habiterait les champs et les forêts et
serait d être ni bon ni mauvais elles
apparaissent aux hommes qu'elle prenne
pour amant et leur apporte fortune
bonheur et beaucoup d'enfants
c'est le cas de 1000 usine dans la
légende est souvent reprise au moyen-âge
tous ces bienfaits disparaissent
cependant si l'homme ronde son serment
envers la fée disparaît elle aussi il
existerait aussi des mauvaises fait
qu'on retrouve dans le roman du 14e
siècle perçe forêt qu'inspire ensuite la
belle au bois dormant l'église comme
d'habitude s'interrogent sur leur nature
pour les verts guillaume dauven le xiiie
siècle les faits sont soit des démons
soit des inventions de vieilles femmes
elles sont finalement intégré à la
religion chrétienne en tant que créature
bienveillante quand elles servent dieu
et créatures malveillantes quand elles
servent le diable au xvème siècle leurs
croyances diminue on préfère parler de
nains ou d'elf à partir du 6e siècle on
parle aussi de nic u sunar des créatures
aquatiques d'origine scandinave à mi
chemin entre l'homme et le cheval
ils seraient responsables d'inondations
et d'autres malheurs et leurs croyances
entraîne le développement du culte d'un
saint nicolas qui en auraient combattu
dans un registre encore plus sombres je
ne vais pas parler des revenants parce
qu'ils ont déjà eu un épisode rien que
pour eux mais deux groupes deux
revenants la mesnie hellequin aussi
appelé chat sauvage ou armée des morts
est décrite au deuxième siècle par corps
de règles vitales
il raconte un groupe de mort diable
femme claire moines chevaliers des
finances sans répit à travers là
pour certains la mesnie représente à la
fois la solidarité et la fureur des
troupes militaires pour d'autres il
s'agit d'un double infernal de la
société médiévale peu comme le monde à
l'envers dans ce trailer kings mais avec
des défunts proche puisque l'auteur d'y
croiser des membres de sa famille
récemment décédé qui le met en garde
contre ses péchés guillaume d'auvergne
dit que ses armées sont l'oeuvre du
démon d'autres teintes leurs récits de
paganisme
il est possible que l'apparition du
purgatoire au 12e siècle soit une
réponse à cette croyance est un moyen
pour ces défunts santerre de trouver
enfin un lieu de repos laménie disparaît
des croyances au 14e siècle
certains territoires où certaines
périodes sont plus propices au
surnaturel que d'autres la nuit et le
moment où les esprits malfaisants se
manifesterait le plus mais en terme
géographique ce sont les zones
frontières à la limite du monde civilisé
qui voit apparaître fait nains et autres
créatures les frontières les montagnes
les forêts les landes et la mère sont
les territoires tampon où se retrouve la
plupart des légendes ses croyances ne
sont pas non plus une invention
médiévale la montagne est considéré
comme un intermédiaire entre l'homme et
les dieux chez tes babyloniens les grecs
avec l'olympe les juifs avec le sinaï et
les chrétiens du cookie le paradis se
situe sur une montagne quelque part en
orient je pourrais faire un épisode sur
les montagnards jours et puis toujours
au 12e siècle l'église fixe la liste des
sept sacrements et en profite pour
interdire certaines pratiques peu
catholiques danser dans les églises ou
devant les cimetières ce qu'on fait
c'est une deuxième fois pour les mêmes
péchés audio de faire pénitence profité
de l'extrême onction pour extorquer des
biens en mourant ou encore baptisé des
enfants dans autre chose que de l'eau ah
bah moi je veux baptisé le gamin dans
pinard matudi fait comme ça ici sa forme
la jeunesse comme dit et puis à partir
du 2ème siècle apparaît le merveilleux
le merveilleux c'est ce qui suscite
l'admiration
l'étonnement qui remet en cause la
raison et le quotidien plus parler
demain mais à la différence des
superstitions le merveilleux est garanti
100% chrétien on trouve du merveilleux
dans les vies de saints où les oiseaux
apporte de la nourriture dans la vie de
tous les jours aussi
berthe de bourgogne aurait ainsi
accouché d'un enfant monstrueux en
punition d'avoir épousé robert le pieux
qui était son cousin produit le
merveilleux sert souvent à faire passer
un message on retrouve aussi largement
le merveilleux dans la littérature
médiévale à travers des créatures lieu
objet magique mais là on s'éloigne un
peu du sujet alors on en reparlera une
autre fois n'empêche qu'on y croit à ce
merveilleux
ce sont les savants anti qu'ils ont dit
donc c'est vrai on l'est du merveilleux
dans les traités de géographie les
vestiaires les encyclopédies il est
principalement issue des orages antique
mais est admis au moyen-âge ce qui
permet de faire entrer des créatures
telles que le phénix la licorne et le
dragon dans le bestiaire médiéval le
merveilleux devient une petite
mythologie et contribuent encore à la
lutte contre les superstitions païenne
qui sont alors remplacés
la copie d ouvrage antique permet qu'à
partir du deuxième siècle apparaissent
une nouvelle tradition orale populaire
qui s'affranchit des croyances anciennes
pour voir apparaître d'autres motifs
comme par exemple la légende du roi
arthur ou le pays de cocagne
mais ça aussi j'en ai déjà parlé tu
radote la superstition a donc une
définition floue ce qui relève de la
superstition pour nous qui vivons dans
une époque plutôt rationnel pouvait
simplement être de la religion pour les
gens du moyen-âge on peut diviser les
superstitions au moyen-âge en trois
périodes le paganisme du haut moyen-âge
le bas moyen-âge ou une séparation se
fait entre les superstitions paysanne et
la culture savante qui adore le
merveilleux et pratique aussi la magie
mais c'est une magie savantes et le
14ème 15ème siècle où la superstition la
magie n'a qu'une origine le diable merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et comme je vous le disais au début cet
épisode a été sponsorisée par mehdi -
car dont je vais vous parler maintenant
à la base mais dis moi car proposer des
boks mensuel de cuisine médiévale dont
je vous ai déjà un peu parlé sur twitter
depuis peu l'entreprise évolue pour
proposer des kits de cuisine médiévale
qui comprennent toujours une recette
issue de travaux de recherche en
histoire de l'alimentation et ses
ingrédients
ces kits seront distribués dans les
boutiques de sites historiques et des
musées
d'ailleurs 11h45 est à la recherche de
partenaires donc fait passer le mot mais
aussi sur leur boutique en ligne où vous
retrouverez également tous les
ingrédients nécessaires
cuisinez comme bas moyen-âge épices
farine hydromel bref pour avoir testé
leurs produits ce sont toujours de
qualité et leur provenance documenté
personnellement au gel sinon je n'aurais
pas fait ce partenariat
oui enfin c'est surtout aliénor qui a
insisté
vous retrouverez donc le lien de leurs
sites dans la description mais aussi au
bas de votre écran actuellement donc
allé voir et maintenant vous pouvez
commenter et faire un tour sur youtube
et et puis on se retrouve le mois
prochain qu il se passe pas un truc sur
la chaîne le mois prochain
je fais pas personnellement je pars en
vacances dans le canapé de you ne
comptez pas sur moi
on en verra j'étais sûr qu'il fait un
truc
je suis justin de france le truc du mois
prochain c'est anwar allez voir ça sera
bien